j'ai beaucoup de gratter
de pouvoir partager
que vous ce soir
une idée qui
inchangé
au monde et qui a une source énorme deux
inspirations et d'espoir pour moi tout a
commencé il ya quelques mois avec un
appel d'un numéro inconnu
j'étais posé sur une colline dans notre
village de promeneurs en dessous d'un
grand frêne avec une belle vue sur un
grand pré de charolaises et les paysages
de l'auxois derrière je réfléchissais
aux prochaines pas dans ma vie comment
réduire le temps de travail sur
ordinateur et mes déplacements
professionnels
j'avais besoin de mont racine et plus
localement et juste à ce moment là mon
portable sonne numéro inconnu
salut en selle ses annales tant
l'arrière petite fille m je comprends
pas mon arrière petite fille ben oui tu
sais la petite-fille de ta grand mère
non la petite fille de tap future fille
ma grand mère j'ai enfin pu la
convaincre de meudon et au numéro parce
que je voulais te remercier tu sais j'ai
grandi ici à promeut loin et j'ai passé
toute mon enfance en jouant dans le
jardin forêt à mille et une espèce et en
courant en courant derrière les les
poules dans les prés arboré et derrière
les vaches dans les forêts fourrage et
en me baignant dans les étangs et donc
pour moi c'est complètement normal qu'il
y a plein d'arbres dans les prés chez
nous et que que nos champs englobe des
dérangés de noyer et de chênes et c'est
toujours été comme ça chez nous et c'est
je connais rien d'autre mais donc
l'autre jour je parlais avec grand mère
et elle me disait que ça n'a pas
toujours été comme ça quand elle était
petite
la plupart des prêts n'avait pas
d'arbres et donc les animaux avait nulle
part où se cacher ou pas de feuilles
basses ou de fruits à manger et elle me
parlait aussi de champ énorme tout
pas une rangée d'arbres dedans même pas
un seul arbre isolé et apparemment il y
avait aussi des vergers que avec des
pommiers et rien au dessus dans le canot
paix ou ou en dessous des petits fruits
ou des arbustes rien et en plus que avec
de la golden mais c'est sûr qu'on prend
pas ça sert à quoi
c'est difficile pour moi à imaginer ça
et est donc et grand-mère il m'a dit que
que c'était votre génération qui ont
planté tous des arbres il y a plus de 60
ans je crois
c'est vrai ça grand papy ans elle est
jeune c'est incroyable que tu me
racontes tout ça parce que justement là
aujourd'hui je me disais que j'aimerais
planter des arbres partout ici autour de
nous et du coup non on ne les appelants
encore planté ses arbres mais on va le
faire c'est sûr on va dire on sème les
graines grand mère il disait vous avez
créé une sorte de coopérative pour un
truc qui s'appelait l'agglo fausse
terrine en passe à l'agro forêt série
voilà c'est ça bon c'est un grand mot
pour dire des arbres partout dans les
prés dans les champs je crois est donc
cette coopérative que vous avez créée
elle faisait partie d'un réseau avec des
lieux partout dans le monde qui eux
aussi planter des arbres chez eux comme
vous et mais apparemment à l'époque les
gens ils ne vous croyais pas trop
il vous prenez un peu comme des fous ben
c'est un âne sais c'est pas tout simple
comment expliquer dans ma génération
nous avons hérité d'une pensée mon nom
mon aux cultures monochrome mon visage
monotone monopole et ma vision c'est de
contribuer à une dynamique dans ma
région qui transformera ses paysages mon
nom
en paysage rempli d'arbres d'animaux et
d'humains des paysages poli pauli genre
bien élevé mêlant poli avec un y
comme pour les usages pour les culturel
polymorphe pour lily chrome et surtout
polyvalent dans la pensée mon nom un
bout de terre nous doit servir qu'à une
chose à produire de l'herbe ou faire
pousser des peupliers bien droit ou bien
un champ de tournesols
si sur un bout terre comme ça il ya des
boulots qui monte spontanément bas c'est
la panique
il faut les couper pourtant ils gênent
pas l'herbe ni les tournesols et il
pouvait produire de la sève de bouleau
est donc peut-être une activité
économique pour quelqu'un mais dans la
pensée mon nom et les lézards bris ne
sert qu'à une chose à faire du bois ou
alors à produire des fruits et donc ça
veut dire en 1 d on a des forêts et des
vergers et après on a aussi des chants
et des prêts mais du coup ils ne
mélangent d2 avec tous les avantages que
ça produit a annoncé c'est trop
compliqué dans dans notre culture
des mots comme tu les utilisent les les
prêts arboré où les forêts fourrage ont
l'économie même pas ces mots là ah ben
oui mais tu sais ça ça va changer ça
j'ai parlé récemment avec m mon oncle et
sylvain et il me disait que dans la
période du grand changement les gens des
régions autour
ils sont venus ici dans les moments de
carros parce que dans chez nous il y
avait assez à manger est assez d'eau à
boire pour tout le monde et plus plus
tard il y a des centaines de réfugiés
qui sont venus et vous avez pu les
accueillir
grâce à la générosité du paysage et au
fur et à mesure à mesure des années
difficiles les gens ils ont ils se sont
inspirés des lieux comme ici
et les autres de votre réseau pour les
arbres et ils se sont mis à en planter
partout dans le monde comme ici mais il
paraît que il a fallu beaucoup de
souffrance pour que les gens changent
d'habitude
oui alors allen 10 - pour réduire cette
souffrance et faire en sorte qu'on
comprend plus rapidement qu'elles sont
pour toi les atouts des arbres ah oui
alors on peut les grimper par exemple tu
t il ya une rangée de châtaignier tout
près de la maison et c'est là où il y
avait des vignes plantées dans la leurs
pieds et l'automne dernier on est monté
on est monté le le tran comme le font
les vignes et on s'est cachés en haut et
on a mangé tout l'ex-rennais coup toutes
les raisins qui était mûr et plus tard
on a dit aux parents qui c'était une
mauvaise année pour les raisons pas mal
ce pipe et j'aime bien mais dis moi il
doit y avoir d'autres atouts encore aux
arbres non et ben oui alors c'est à
réfléchir il
il nous donne à manger à nous et à nos
amis m'ont et ils produisent le sol
ils produisent du sol ah au fait tu
connais la fête de la machette
ben non c'est quoi ah bah alors tu as
aimé je te raconte deux fois par an à la
fin de l'hiver et la fin de la récolte
en rassemble tout le village et des amis
viennent aussi et en prend chacun une
machette bling et il ya quelqu'un qui
monte sur le tracteur équipé de grands
sécateur et là on traverse les gens les
forêts les petites près avec les grands
et et en coupe et en coupe et en coupe
et en coupe et toutes les branches qui
tombent par terre
bailly vont ils vont recréer le sol pour
les générations futures
parfois plus d'un centimètre par an et
dont les branches qu'en coupe parfois
on s'en sert aussi pour du bois de
chauffage de cuisson ou encore de
construction où on en fait des outils ou
des piquets mais la plupart des branches
elles restent quand même par terre et
redeviennent du sol et et dont le soir
en enlever un grand feu et en danse
autour avec nos machette pas mal j'aime
cette idée aussi mais quoi d'autre alors
qu'est ce qui nous donne encore les
arbres un homme alors il nous donne pas
de lambres et il nous protège du vent et
a oui il ya aussi apparemment ils
contribuent à la haye la pluviométrie
alors qui oscille 20 ans mon oncle et si
van os il m'a expliqué sa il disait que
co dans son enfance il y avait beaucoup
de sécheresse moi j'en ai vécu qu'une
seule mais lui il disait les arbres qui
nous protège de la sécheresse mais il
m'a pas trop expliquer comment tu sais
toi ben ouais je peux essayer je crois
qu'il ya deux choses premièrement plus
il y as d'arbres diversifié dans un
paysage avec leurs feuilles qui tombent
et les branches qu'en coupe comme à la
fête de la machette
plus ça va créer un sol riche qui va
pouvoir retenir l'eau est comme une
éponge et donc c'est pour ça qu'il ya
souvent plus de sources dans un paysage
avec plein d'arbres et deuxièmement et à
l'histoire du cycle de l'eau ah oui ça
je connais l'eau donc il pleut l'eau
ruisselle dans les rivières jusqu'à la
mer puis
l'été va pour et par le soleil et ça
revient en forme de nuage et il peut de
nouveau
ouais bravo exactement c'est ça donc ça
c'est ce qu'on appelle le cycle long de
l'eau et après y'a le cycle court de
l'eau aussi où une partie de l'eau
remonte directement du paysage sans
passer par la mer et donc c'est l'eau
qui est retenu dans le sol et dans tout
ce qui est vivant sur terre même en où
il ya de l'eau et les plantes comme nous
il transpire et sophie transpire
beaucoup plus que nous et les arbres
surtout il transpire beaucoup et ça on
appelle ça
l'évapotranspiration et cette eau
contribuer à la formation de nuages
je comprends non mais tu veux dire plus
en plants d'arbres dans une vallée par
exemple plus il va plus voir dans cette
fin voilà c'est exactement ça donc tu
vas la quantité d'arbres
elle est liée elle a une relation
positive à la pluviométrie je peux te
donner un exemple j'ai vécu plusieurs
années en jordanie un pays très très
très sec où il ya une région qui
s'appelle ajlnh et c'est la seule région
du pays qui a des forêts et comme par
hasard c'est la région qui reçoit le
plus depuis environ quatre fois la
moyenne du pays
bon je crois qu'on a compris l'histoire
de l'eau mais moi j'aimerais te poser de
trois questions
ok vas-y m'est fait et vite parce que je
vois mes amis ils préparent les affaires
pour aller à la pêche la pêche super bas
je me dépêche alors écoute en plus de
tous ces avantages que tu as des cris
des arbres ils produisent du sol il
augmente la pluie
dubois et
et plein d'autres choses dans ma
génération
en plus de tout ça en plantent les
arbres surtout pour leur capacité de
séquestrer du co2 de l'atmosphère et
donc de réduire le réchauffement
climatique climatique et donc je me
demande dans ta génération le co2 et
tout ça c'est encore un souci
nous on n'a pas de problème avec le co2
non c'est quoi ta deuxième question
ouais ok voilà super alors deuxième
question oui le problème des abeilles
vous en ai tout ça on est tous voilà là
alors les habits c'est un problème et on
a tellement ils n'arrêtent pas rentrer
chez nous et à je peux plus manger une
tartine dehors mais on aime quand même
le miel donc pouf c'est génial
d'entendre ça alors ma dernière question
un âne
tu peux me donner à une idée peut-être
comment je peux inspirer ou comment je
peux ouvrir les esprits des gens de ma
génération qui pense mon nom tu vois
comment je peux le raid et a déjà
imaginé ce paysage dans lequel tu vis et
peut-être à en planter des arbres et à
coopérer mais on s'aime mais c'est
évident il faut que tu en plantes
toi-même d'abord au caire amman a tu as
raison écoute c'est c'est une chose
promis ça ça c'est sûr
bah écoutes je te remercie pour ton
appel ça m'a touché profondément et je
te souhaite bonne pêche est ok merci à
toi et les autres pour tous ces arbres
un à bientôt
à bientôt j'espère dans cette histoire
je ne vous ai pas trop parler de pénurie
de famine de guerre d'effondrement est
ce qu'on vous prouve est ce qu'on va
pouvoir les éviter en plantant des
arbres le changement climatique
on en parlera plus dans 60 ans
franchement je sais pas mais une chose
c'est sûr notre espèce a beaucoup plus
de chances de survivre dans un paysage
rempli d'arbres que dans un paysage tout
nu comme diane et c'est quelque chose
auquel on peut tous contribué en france
par exemple il ya les croqueurs de
pommes qui distribue des arbres greffés
pas cher il ya les incroyables
comestibles qui transforme des boues
terre en ville en qui les rend
comestibles il ya des associations pour
l'agroforesterie qui travaille avec des
producteurs et qui font parfois des
journées plantation où on peut aller
planter
après il ya des communes qui ont des
terres ce sont nos terres commun et on
peut créer un groupe citoyen vers un
plan et en parler avec le maire ou la
mer
après certains parmi vous sont peut être
des agriculteurs où vous en avez des
amis qui sont agriculteurs
êtes vous conscient de tous ces
avantages multiples et surprenant qu'ils
nous offrent les arbres je vous donne
deux petites exemple des éleveurs en
australie ont pu augmenter leur
production de viande par hectare par
jusqu'à 10 10 10 fois la quantité en
plantant des milliers d'arbres dans
leurs pâturages et en france le projet
sif a pu montrer qu'on peut produire en
associant des cultures céréaliers avec
des arbres on peut produire jusqu'à 60%
plus de biomasse dans de poids total de
la plante dans une culture une dernière
idée vous mangez tous des pêches et des
noix et si on prenait une habitude de
garder noyaux de pêche et à chaque fois
qu'on fait une balade on les prend avec
nous et quelques loin et peut-être un
gland ou une châtaigne et on se ballade
en si on trouve un un petit coin quelque
part qui a l'air de pouvoir ou vouloir
accueillir un arbre ben plantant le
c'est certainement pas une solution
magique et c'est un pas quand peut tous
faire donc
pensant un aux arrières petites filles
et plantons des arbres